[Music]
well william harry kate and megan came
together to view tributes to the queen
on saturday at windsor in a show of
apparent unity but after the way the
sussexes have badmouthed the monarchy
for the last couple of years should they
be forgiven and welcome back
or will harry's forthcoming tell all
book actually make things a lot worse
joining me on discussions former royal
protection officer ken war family law
barrister paul of rhone adrian
ambassador photographer arth roberts is
still with me
ken
this is a hard one isn't it because my
understanding of what actually happened
was that prince william now the new
prince of wales could see that the
entire week was going to get taken up
the stories of the rift and who was
going to sit where at the various
ceremonies and so on and he thought he'd
get ahead of it as my understanding and
he texted harry and said we're going to
go on a walk about
why don't you come as well and let's
just try and defuse things and harry
agreed and then they spent 45 minutes
getting ready because they weren't
expecting it and then they all went out
together there was no doubt it's a
powerful image of unity but i don't
think anyone should be too fooled that
this actually
is the end of the problem and one of the
biggest issues is this tell-all book
that harry has written which is due to
be published by penguin random house we
don't know when potentially even in the
next couple of months
and if it does and it's really critical
of the man who's now king his father and
is critical of the woman who's now queen
console and it's critical of the heir to
the throne the prince of wales prince
william this is going to cause
incredible new damage probably worse
than anything they've done already what
do you think of this
well i mean i agree i agree with what
you're saying i mean if if what you say
were to appear in this book and and if
this book were to be published within
the next or the foreseeable future and
and if that's what's written that it is
going to cause you know
i think extraordinary damage
my personal belief is i think that you
know this will be put on hold for the
for the immediate future well i've
written a column tonight for the new
york post saying i think he should
cancel it well i think he should rip up
the contract and cancel it because he's
given a statement today harry a very
heartwarming statement about his
grandmother as you would expect they
were close but you can't get away from
the hurt that she must have experienced
in the last two years over all the
shenanigans coming out of california and
in the towards the end of the statement
he says you know he now wants to honor
his father king charles iii how do you
honor the new king with a book which he
says is going to be searingly
honest and accurate which of course is
what we were told the oprah interview
was what turned out not to be i think
it's i think you you could be right i
mean calling for this to be to be pulled
probably a good idea but i think when do
you think what the prince what the king
has said now that he you know would want
you know wants harry i think really to
be part of this new plan of his you know
to take the monarchy forward i mean he
said this some years ago before we had
this does harry want to be part of it or
does megan in particular
actually want to carry on having their
royal cake and eat it in california and
to not have to abide by the rules of
doing any duty or service or anything
like that but to do exactly what they
want yeah but what makes yourselves very
rich but one thing's certainly i mean
look at the pictures of harry in the
last 24 hours you know he doesn't look
happy in this role i mean certainly i
think he was pleased to be there yeah
you know to to show respect for his
grandmother
and and with his wife megan but
the whole point is that that somehow
there has to be a deal struck either
we're going to say goodbye forever and i
know that you've said that the title
should be taken away as well but i think
so at some point if they're gonna well
paul let's bring you in here because
you're a supporter of them you know i
just think
the two things aren't compatible you
can't keep royal titles and exploit them
in the way that they're doing for
personal enrichment from the other side
of the world it just doesn't fly i don't
think for most people in this country
interestingly as i'm talking to you
oprah winfrey has said that queen
elizabeth uh seconds death could be an
opportunity for peacemaking speaking at
the toronto film festival she said well
this is what i think i think in all
families you know my father passed
recently this summer when all families
come together for a common ceremony the
ritual of burying your debt there's an
opportunity for peacemaking and
hopefully there will be that she told
that to uh extra so obviously there's
that opportunity and obviously it was
encouraging to see the four of them
coming out and obviously everybody would
like them to all get on and to be
promoting the new king and the new
monarchy but the problem is i don't
think that this picture
is the end of the problem
and and i agree with you actually on
this point piers it's not
the complete picture but what we do have
is we have
a positive progression we have a coming
together because what unfortunately
grieving can do is it can also tear you
apart but we haven't seen that well
harry apparently look you don't know
quite what to believe in the reports but
harry reportedly went up to balmoral
with the rest of the family and left in
the morning and never spoke to william
which this is as the queen was dying i
find that an extraordinary effect
but if that is true it shows you the
scale of the rift
but in in terms of moving forward i'd
actually like to think that king charles
had something to do with this as well
apparently he didn't and it's very clear
it was all william's idea
his speech i think really reached out to
many of those watching um and i would be
surprised and if therefore on the
sidelines he didn't play a role he is
their father afterwards
you know
you know all these people very well you
know charles extremely well william
extremely well
this has been a hell of a mess and i
feel quite angry that this was all
what the queen had to deal with actually
in the last two years the last thing she
would have wanted particularly when
philip got ill and then died i mean the
last thing she wanted was her
grandchildren at war and everything else
what do you make of it what did you make
of the the rapprochement for this
picture of them coming out together
what do you think the answer is going
forward well when the prince said he
loved harry and megan that shook me as
well in his speech and then when they
well i mean when megan got out the car i
was amazed but
obviously william
has got to sort of do something about it
and he spoke to his brother and said
look let's
let's make a combined effort here but
they did it because
if they if megan had turned up for the
funeral on monday
all the papers has been talking about
megan and prince of wales and principals
the king doesn't want that he wants it's
all about
the queen yeah nothing else there are no
distractions
whether they'll get back together i
don't know i mean there's there's a big
strong rift between there's a huge risk
i mean he's good ken i mean you were
diana's bodyguard
she would have hated what's happened
between her two sons wouldn't she well
yeah but she would have done but i've
said before piers you know what this
this this this rift needed was someone
to broker a deal or someone to sort this
out and you know that you know diana had
gone through you said her short life you
know with a great deal of anxiety a
great deal of unhappiness and would have
seen the problems here and would have
seen the the long-term problems here
because the problem is really you know
nobody really wants
quite frankly i know your view on the
view of many thousands of others but
they they need someone to combine this
or to to mend it to find out to find a
solution to put it right and i think
diana would have been the person to deal
with that well i think i don't think is
that complic it is complicated in the
sense of i mean paul when they left the
sussexes when they left the royal family
in britain in january 2020 you know it
seems forever again but when they left
they said they were that whatever
happened they were going to uphold the
values of her majesty even though if
they weren't going to be doing duty on
her behalf i don't think even their
wildest supporters could say that their
behavior in the last two years has
upheld the values of her majesty the
queen i don't think that's fair pierce
really because what we know she
represented duty
themselves to the tune of hundreds of
millions of people
and i do yeah but the work that they do
for their charities is designed to
reinforce their royal status which they
then flees to the highest bidders
they've been paid a fortune by netflix
there's this documentary coming out
about their love story which if that
contains more damaging allegations about
the royal family will be another chip to
this new king and the monarchy now you
say damaging allegations about the royal
family what we are actually talking
about is a son talking about his home no
you're talking about talking about a
daughter-in-law talking about her pain
yeah it's something that that isn't
unusual in anything i'm not sure how
painful it is to take your prince
from his country back to california and
make yourself super rich
trading off your newly found royal
stages i'm not sure how painful that is
particularly to most millions of people
in britain who are currently on the
bread line in this cost of living crisis
her pain i think needs to be put into
some perspective well the pain she's
there
the pain she's called the royal family
and harry's behavior is called the royal
family to me outweighs their own little
local difficulties suggestion that you
can have one without well when you call
the royal family well when you call the
royal family a bunch of callous races
you don't actually produce any evidence
to prove it i have a problem with that
and when you carry on
spewing nonsense like meghan markle
recently just said this interview last
week that she had you know thank god her
children aren't at school in england
because they'd have 50 paparazzi every
day we know that's not going to happen
there are rules to stop that happening
well it wouldn't happen with the english
press but we know that it would happen
with the internet final words do you
think they're going to all get
reconciled any time soon absolutely
should harry get rid of his book
no
really wow ken because i do think that a
lot has been said about the way that
king charles is going to take this
monarchy forward i think what he will do
he will find a way of reconciling harry
with the rest of the royal family quite
what that will be i don't know should he
pop the book
i don't think he should pull the book at
this stage i think what he should do is
actually not do anything with it but
reflect on it and realize seriously what
damage that might do okay arthur
yeah and i i think uh
you know the quicker harry gets back
here and starts supporting his father
and his brother the better uh whether
she comes in or not i don't think see i
don't think that's going to happen
anytime soon but you know
i think thank you for coming in i know
what this must have meant to you this
last few days so i really appreciate you
coming in okay and uh great that you're
carrying on working with our new king
because he'll need you yeah i'd like to
see everybody 82 ken i've got to retire
yeah paula thank you both very much